welcome back 6 15. the Super Bowl is
this weekend good day Las Vegas counting
down to the big game all week long you
know the pro bowlers they're waking up
here in Las Vegas but the super Bowlers
they're just south of us in Glendale
Arizona and that's where we find our
very own Sasha Loftus this morning Sasha
good morning thanks for waking up early
with us
of course good morning Heather it's nice
to be up early I never get to see you
because of course we're on opposite
shifts but out here at the Super Bowl
here it is beautiful it is very exciting
the Super Bowl week heading into that
Sunday game here in Glendale the sun
just came up it's really going to be a
beautiful day as all those fans come in
and of course the teams are here as well
both the Chiefs and the Eagles both
arrived yesterday getting ready for that
big media night here of course in
Phoenix now quarterback Jalen hurts
leading the Eagles off the plane as the
NFC champions they're looking for their
second Super Bowl title now QB Patrick
Mahomes and star Titan Travis Kelsey
they're bringing the Chiefs to Phoenix
as they make their third trip to the big
game in just the last four years now the
Eagles and the Chiefs practicing all
week here in Tempe that's about 30
minutes from the stadium in Glendale the
Chiefs will be at the campus at Arizona
State the Eagles will head to the
Arizona Cardinals facilities now as I
mentioned the first big order of
business is that media night tonight
will all the players will be talking to
reporters a lot of story lines going
along with this particular game of
course two African-American quarterbacks
starting that's the first time that's
ever happened also two brothers facing
off the Kelsey's one on each team and
then of course the chief the Chiefs head
coach Andy Reed is facing his former
team he was the coach of the Eagles back
in 2012. so just a lot to talk about a
lot to look forward to a lot of fans
arriving here already we've seen fans
from all different teams not just the
Chiefs and the Eagles but all teams
across the league so we're excited to be
here everyone else is excited to be here
and we're excited to share with you all
week oh it is fun while Eagles of course
favored to win as of now so we'll see so
no question is off the table so Sasha we
look forward to hearing what you ask
thank you Sasha